encantado exploradora bote
el supuesto enemigo está a la derecha y
vamos a entrar en contacto para hacer
retroceder su ataque del grupo
estos hombres nos fueron presentados
como oficiales de reserva del ejército
ruso todos han luchado en la región
separatista del donbass
[Música]
el grupo se entrena en tácticas de
combate en un bosque de la región de
moscú un entrenamiento que según su
líder dimitri burón es completamente
rutinario pero dicen que ahora están
listos para luchar de verdad y estoy
para trébol si es necesario nuestra
unión de voluntarios del donbass entrará
en el campo de batalla para defender al
pueblo ruso del donbass a cuatro puestos
pero estas habilidades no serán útiles
aquí en la vaquita estanca de estas
medallas espera usted un escenario así
pronto
usted puede imaginarse que con una
escalada como ésta esperamos que se
produzca
este mensaje de defensa del pueblo ruso
en el donbass ha sido expandido por el
kremlin desde el comienzo del conflicto
en la región oriental de ucrania
en moscú la organización de combatientes
rusos en el donbass está dirigida por
alexander de oro del primer dirigente de
la entidad separatista que se
autoproclamó como república popular de
donnet
rusia no puede permanecer indiferente y
no intervenir cuando comience el
genocidio del pueblo ruso en el donbass
les recuerdo que desde 2018 rusia ha
estado distribuyendo pasaportes en el
donbass hoy en día unas 800.000 personas
que viven permanentemente en el donbass
son ciudadanos rusos
gracias
según alexander toro de la guerra
abierta se ha vuelto ahora inevitable
sus palabras se hacen eco con las del
kremlin que dice que la culpa es de
ucrania colonizada por la otan